as much as negativity and garbage that
he's gone through look at how despite
the massive unfair social media
cancellation that he's gone through look
at how he has still been ever been able
to overcome this while on house arrest
he was tweeting from prison and still
pissing people off and red pilling
people harder so yeah I mean you know
he's he is I mean if they try to kill
him too all they're going to do is make
a massive martyr out of him right so you
know I just I want nothing but the best
for the guy I think he's going to get
out okay and if they do slap him with
something you know it's just going to be
people seeing like a massive Injustice
in the world and that's just going to
piss off the masses more and wake more
people up to the treachery of government
the elites and all this